on va parler musique aujourd'hui on va
parler d'écouteurs et vous en ai déjà
parlé avec quelques temps les écouteurs
de diva corps ce sont les nomades et au
cachot à la jolie acrobaties et nous
être plus
[Musique]
l'idée des écouteurs trouvailles en
laisse c'est en fait vous avez deux
boîtes que vous expliquer pourquoi parce
que là vous avez jusqu'à 15 heures
musique là vous avez jusqu'à 180 musique
ce sont exactement les mêmes écouteurs
la même qualité ce sont les nomades
nomades plus la différence c'est que
dans celui ci vous avez une peau leur
banque de 5000 millan paire eur tandis
que là dessus vous avez une batterie de
420 millions paire eur permettra de
recharger vos écouteurs 3 à 4 fois
tandis que là vous avez vous pouvez
recharger un paquet de fois vous pouvez
même recharger votre téléphone portable
avec par sa femme tout moment que je
déteste et je trouve cool vraiment
intéressant mais avant toute chose je
voulais montrer d'un peu plus près ce
qui est vachement cool et que j'aime
beaucoup de ces boîtes c'est que hope
pour trouver avec ça ça c'est super joli
c'est le petit boîtier que vous avez
alors là c'est le nomade et là vous avez
le nomade plus bon franchement à choisir
esthétiquement tu préfères le nomade
je trouve vachement plus jolie vous
pressez vous ouvrez et à l'intérieur
vous avez vos petits bugs vos petits
écouteurs intra auriculaires je voulais
montrer dans quelques instants
franchement et sur super super super
super cool vous pouvez recharger bien
évidemment ici là vous avez des petits
connecteurs vous y retrouvez aussi à
l'arrière ici bon ça c'est un grand
classique et vont charger sa directement
en micro usb sur les nomades plus c'est
une autre affaire la fusée prix de
couleurs vraiment différente elle existe
soit en blanc soit en modèle noir comme
ça j'aime bien les deux après c'est
vraiment une question de goût la vraie
grosse différence est que sans les
nommer de plus et une power banque vous
à les recharger en micro usb donc ça pas
forcément est très très vite par contre
là vous avez une prise usb type arabe
vous allez pouvoir recharger votre
smartphone votre voyage ce que vous
voulez avec tout en sachant que vous
avez comme je le disais 5000 millions
terreur à l'intérieur par charge
complète des écouteurs vous avez à peu
près trois heures d'autonomie
franchement trois ans d'autonomie c'est
largement suffisant pour ce que vous
avez en faire je vous dis une fois de
plus un jeudi à chaque fois mais évitez
d'écouter de la musique un volume fort
de façon trop prolongée dans nos
oreilles pour une petite vous rendre
sourd perso je les aime bien
il trouve assez facilement leur place
dans chacune de vos oreilles conscient
que vous avez trois modèles différents
ici pour pouvoir avoir vraiment quelque
chose qui correspond complètement à vos
oreilles vous les synchroniser à votre
smartphone
c
du bluetooth 5.0 ça marche super bien la
collection est vraiment vraiment
vraiment cool là au bout d'un petit peu
de musique comme ça j'écoute en même
temps directement devant vous à se
mettre un peu de musique allemande parce
que j'adore avec ses écouteurs c'est
qu'il ya une vraie bonne qualité audio
des loques vous avez positionner
correctement dans votre oreille vous
avez même des baux grave et en règle
générale c'est assez rare sur les petits
écouteurs intra auriculaires comme ça
d'avoir un fonds avec du grave alors la
basse n'en parlons pas n'a pas de quoi
développer un son avec beaucoup de bath
mais je trouve que le spectre tout cas
est vraiment pas mal
les médiums sont cools les aigus sont
assez précis et les graves sont là une
fois de plus ça dépend vraiment du
positionnement dans vos oreilles
donc bon premier temps que d'aller
positionner moyens truc qui m'a un petit
peut poser problème au début c'est le
fait trouvé vraiment la bonne position
dans mes oreilles
il aurait tendance un petit peu glissé
et à partir alors il a fallu tourner le
chercher s'il trouvait la bonne taille
il fait j'ai trouvé le bon compromis la
bonne position salée au début je crois
que c'est pas hyper hyper hyper pratique
mais vous d une fois que j'ai trouvé ça
va ça roule autre point sympa ce sont
les appels stéréo vous avez vos
écouteurs dans chaque oreille et lorsque
vous avez ressenti cucchi vous allez
entendre
de chaque côté bon ça c'est aussi pas
mal mais ce qui est vraiment intéressant
avec ses écouteurs c'est le mode sport
parce que vous avez une petite réduction
bruit passive c'est pas une son bruit
actif comme vous allez avoir dans
certains cas ce qui coûte tout de suite
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de chiens
mais par contre déjà du fait de la main
comme ça vous allez vous boucher un peu
l'oreille donc a déjà une réduction de
bruit mais vous avez quand même une
petite réduction de bruit passive et ça
peut aussi être un frein lorsqu'il
allait faire du sport en extérieur à
savoir lorsque vous allez courir dans la
rue à et faire du jogging vous n'allez
pas forcément entendre tout ce qui se
passe autour du cou dit l'accord s'est
dit on va pallier un petit peu à ça on
va permettre aux personnes d'aller
cliquer ici
ça va activer le micro qui va venir
amplifier les soins extérieurs
non pas que vous ne voyez plus votre
musique tout simplement vous puissiez
courir faire du vélo faire une activité
outdoor en toute sécurité et ça pour le
coup c'est plutôt pas mal
maintenant si un petit reproche que je
peux leur faire ce qu'ils sont en
permanence en train clignoter c'est à la
fois sympa sauf que le problème c'est
lorsque vous êtes dans des
environnements où il n'y a pas forcément
beaucoup de lumière je pense à un avion
sur un voyage de nuit je pense à un
train sur des choses comme ça on va
forcément vous repérer alors bon c'est
qu'une fois de plus c'est du pain de
détail 1 mais voilà ça c'est un le truc
ça aurait été bien de pouvoir le
désactiver ou alors que servir
uniquement clignoter
lorsque vous l'allumez mais pas en
permanence à côté de ça c'est aussi la
marque de fabrique de ce produit c'est
pas très important mais ça pourrait
poser problème à certains d'entre vous
le gros plus de ces produits c'est
vraiment l'autonomie l'autonomie parce
que comme je le dis vous avez votre
recharge
là vous allez jusqu'à 15h déjà 15 heures
sans avoir à le recharger
c'est franchement cool pour y voir venir
vous avez vraiment le contraire tout ce
que vous voulez et l'a carrément avec la
power donc de 5000 clients terreur 180
heures de musique c'est franchement
complètement dingue là c'est un produit
qui est plus destiné aux voyageurs à des
personnes qui ont toutes en prendre
l'avion pour des raisons pro règle
générale demain que vous souhaitez tout
le temps en vacances vous fassiez le
tour du monde en permanence mais la 180
heures musique c'est complètement ou
alors après on pourrait se dire que
trois en musique uniquement d'un trait
et après il ya plus de batterie ça
pourrait être un frein d'un autre côté
je vois pas l'intérêt d'écouter trois
heures musique en permanence imaginez
par exemple vous êtes en avions même si
vous faites un vol de six heures un vol
de huit heures est-ce que vous allez
avoir envie d'écouter de la musique
pendant trois heures non-stop
personnellement tout cas vraiment
pertinents peut-être que certains diront
oui moi pas nécessairement je l'écouté
de la musique pendant une heure pendant
deux heures
moi je vous le rababou kiné dormir
regarde un film et du coup ce que je
fais à ce moment-là je l'aimais là
dedans ça se recharge et ça me permet à
près de réécouter un peu plus tard c'est
un parti pris lé là qu'ils se diront je
vais écouter tout le temps lontan
bon voilà ça c'est vraiment à chacun de
voix en tout cas à trois zones cno me
moi ça me paraît vraiment convenable et
tu pouvoir la recharger directement avec
sa power banques ça je trouve aussi que
c'est un point très positif
on a donc des produits que je trouve moi
personnellement cool je vous dis le gros
point de reproches un petit peu que je
pourrais faire c'est vraiment ici ça
clignote tout le temps la difficulté au
début a trouvé vraiment la position dans
son oreille ça c'est vraiment voilà les
deux poings un petit peu négatif de ce
produit par contre une fois vous êtes
habitué il faut que vous allez bien en
main la qualité audio est bien le son
est cool
il n'y a absolument pas de déconnexion
ça c'est bien merci le bluetooth 5.0 et
surtout la grosse autonomie ça c'est
vraiment un point qui est extrêmement
forts sur ces écouteurs j'avais
rencontré l'équipe de diva corps il ya
quelques temps lorsque j'étais à l'ifa à
berlin c'était adorable l épreuve j'ai
trouvé hyper cool très content de
pouvoir et esthète parce que ça des
produits qui trouve intéressant je me
demande ce qu'on va nous sortir d'yves
accord en deux
19 les antipodes en 2017 et les nomades
et novell plus en 2019 voir ce qui va
arriver l'année prochaine en 2019
attendant je sais pas si c'est des
produits qui pourrait vous intéresser
moi je trouve plutôt pas mal et ce qui
coule là tu sais que c'est une belle
alternative pour tous les possesseurs
d'android qui veulent vraiment des
écouteurs pour écouter de la musique
avec leur smartphone et qui veulent pas
non plus dépenser des sommes
complètement dingue parce que les
nomades vous allez trouver à 99 euros
tout rond
c'est plutôt pas mal et les nomades plus
avec la power manque 2,5 millions
terreur vous les trouvez à 119 euros
d'ailleurs si vous intéresse je vous ai
mis un lien en bas dans la description
voilà puis dites moi vous en commentaire
ce que vous lequel vous préférez est ce
que vous préférez le modèle blanc est ce
que vous préférez le modèle noir
à vous de choisir remarquez tout ça en
bas en commentaire c'est d'autres
produits à vous présenter leur nodo
dites moi en commentaire si ça vous
intéresse
quant à nous je vous souhaite
d'excellentes fêtes de fin d'année
moment je tournais la vidéo ma longue
période de noël donc je vous souhaite
d'excellentes fêtes de fin d'année 1
et puis continuez d'écouter de la
musique et surtout mettez pas le son
trop fort et vite et vous rend toujours
5ème dommage
à bientôt ocha